وصف المتحدث باسم الكريم
هولندا ودول البلطيق بانها عدوانيه للغايه
وقال ان من المخزن ان الدول الاوروبيه
الكبرى لا تضع حدا لها حسب قوله وضاف
بسكوف ان دون البلطيق وفولندا على استعداد
للفعل كل ما يثير المزيد من المواجهه مع
روسيا دون التفكير في العواقب
تاتي هذه التصريحات ردا على تصريحات
لرئيسه ليتوانيا حاثه فيها دول النيتو على
تجاوز الخطوط الحمراء ومنح اوكرانيا
الطائرات المقاتله والصواريخ وفي السياق
ذاته قال ان القياده الروسيه وثقه من ان
قرار بدء العمليه العسكريه الخاصه في
اوكرانيا كان صحيحا وضروريا لانقاذ سكان
زومبا حسب قوله
اعلانات وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه النائبه
الوزير
رياضكو فالتقي اليوم سفيره الولايات
المتحده الجديده لدى موسكو
وقالت الوزاره في بيان النار
بحثا مسائله الرقابه على التسلح دون اعطاء
المزيد من التفاصيل
من موسكو ينظم
تطورات عديده وتصريحات كثيره منها تسريحات
زياد والسفير الامريكيه والقضايا التي
نقشت في تثير الانتباه
الجزء الاول من سؤالك فيما يتعلق بتصريحات
الكريمن طبعا هذا همم هذه التصريحات التي
اطلقها ديسكوف تاتي كما ذكرنا في الخبر
ردا على تصريحات ممثله لرئيس الليطوانيه
فيما يتعلق بضروره التخطي الخطوط الحمراء
والتزويد اوكرانيا بطائرات براي موسكو
المواقف المتطرفه لما تصفها همم
عفوا تصف موسكو مواقف وهولندا والدول
البطيخ باعتبارها اكثر الدول المحرضه على
المد اوكرانيا بالاسلحه الهجوميه التي
يمكن ان تطال على العمق الروسي بان هذه
الدول بموقف هذه المتطرفه لا تواجه بمواقف
همم من الدول المحركه في ال- في الاتحاد
الاوروبي في اشاره الى دول الكبرى التي
برايها ما تدير العمليه همم اوكرانيا وان
هذه الخطوات العنايه يمكن ان تدفع في
المواجهه اكثر فاكثر باتجاه
الصدامه المباشر بين روسيا ودول الاوروبيه
المنضويه تحت اللوائح في شمال الاطلسي
ولكن ايضا لمتحدث بالنسبه لكريم لياكد انه
مهما تم مدك اوكرانيا باسلاح هذا لن يغير
ولن يساهم باي شكل من الاشكال في تغيير
مجرى الاحداث على الارض
فيما يتعلق بها الجزئيه الاخرى وهي ايضا
مهمه همم بشان
صحه العمليه العسكريه الروسيه برايه لكن
همم بسكويت تحدث عن مساله اعتراف
المشاركين في رباعيه نورماندي التي تواصلت
الى الاتفاق مسك الثاني كمان اعلم الرئيس
الفرنسي السابق هولاند والمستشاره
الالمانيه السابقه انجيلامر كل رئيس
الاوكرانيا السابق
باراشينكو اللذين اعترفوا في تصريحات
صحفيه بانهم كانوا يحاولون فقط كسب الوقت
في اتفاقيات نسوا وقال ان رباعيه
النورماندي كانت تستخدم فقط كواجهها همم
تمويه من اجل دعم اوكراني عسكريا وبالتالي
قرار الكريم الدخول في العمليه العسكريه
كان صائبا من اجل حمايه المواطنين الروس
او الذين يتقون باللغه الروسيه في دمباز
فيما يتعلق بلقاءات همم نائب وزير
الخارجيه الروسي مع السفيره الامريكيه
الجديده هذا ثاني لقاء في خلال يومين امس
يعني تريسي وتلقى منها اوراق اعتمادها
الجديده للولايات المتحده الامريكيه في
هذا توقيت الصعب للعلاقات بين البلدين
واليوم يلتقي بها مجددا في مبنى وزاره
الخارجيه ويبحث معها ربما النقاط الاكثر
تقارب انا والتي يمكن ان يتحدث بها الروس
الامريكيون والمتعلقه بالرقابه على التسلح
ومسائل التوازن الاستراتيجي التي فعليا لم
تنقطع بشكل كامل رغم كل الاحداث الاخيره
التي تشهدها القاره الاوروبيه في ضوء
الحرب في اوكرانيا واضافه الى انقطاع
فعليا لكل الاتصالات بين روسيا الامريكيين
على مختلف المجالات الدبلوماسيه مع بقاء
طبعا الاتصالات العسكريه متواصله في
مناسبه عده همم وبالتالي هذه لقاءات ربما
تبشر على نقال هكذا ما تتناوله الصحافه
الروسيه بان السفير الجديده ربما تحاول ان
تفتح مع موسكو الصفحه الجديده فيما يتعلق
بالعوده الى الحوار رغم كل الصعوبات في
طبيعه العلاقات بين البلددين
صور زواج مدير مكتب الجزيره في موسكو شكرا
جزيلا لك